well I thought I would like to give a
gift to the audience a little bit of a
Christmas gift I thought about what that
gift might be and uh part of the problem
is I don't want to spend any money
because I'm cheap so I'm going to give a
gift that is uh free and that is my
advice pontificating that's the one
thing that I can do and so we're gonna
go to the uh to Reddit oh God no no
to find some Christmas related
quandaries people who are looking for
advice especially parenting advice
around the holidays around Christmas and
see if we can't sort through this and uh
just help Enlighten uh some people and
the masses so we'll start with this is
Christmas gross I loved Christmas as a
kid it always has been a big deal
holiday for me but I have a two-year-old
who doesn't quite get it yet and
explaining things to him is leaving a
gross taste in my mouth it feels like
Christmas is so much about wanting for
children for teaching them to want
things to ask for things to expect
things don't get me started on the good
versus bad thing we would never go there
wait what
don't get me started on the good versus
bad thing we would never go you would
never go there and explaining the
difference between good versus bad well
maybe you should go there maybe that
should be the first thing that you do as
a parent if you're not going to go there
as a parent then you might as well just
call it a day now because you you've get
there's that's like your your number one
job as a parent is to help a child
understand good versus bad and to walk
the path towards good so
anyway we'll continue I don't want to be
the Grinch killjoy parent but ugh it's
all just so
Ugg like taking him to see Santa who's
going to ask him what he wants it all
feels so much like teaching kids to
focus their identity and Joy on being
consumers
you know there's this concept you hear
from liberals sometimes where they say
problematize
um they talk about problematizing
something and that means making
something into a problem when it's not
and this is a specialty of liberals
they're very good at it's the only thing
they're good at problematizing now I
don't know if this person is a liberal
the comment about good versus evil
certainly makes it sound like she is now
I'm not saying that that materialism
isn't a problem it is especially around
Christmas
but I am saying that that there is no
problem
with a two-year-old getting excited
about getting presents
it's not a problem okay that's normal
now you said yourself I loved Christmas
as a kid well then let your kid love it
too don't make it don't make a thing out
of it right this is so much now of like
older Generations this is what they do
now where there are things that they
enjoyed as kids and it was great they
remember it fondly but now they're
turning back around to make that thing
they enjoyed as kids a problem to make
it complicated to like steal some of
that Joy that they had for because like
pulling the ladder back up uh behind you
as you climb it that's kind of what's
Happening Here don't let your current
adult Hang-Ups Rob your child of the
same Joy
that you experienced that's all okay how
do you handle a holiday like Christmas
parents and in-laws expectations are
already stressing us out we're
struggling to plan our first Christmas
with a baby pre-baby my wife would go
see your parents for the day while I
would go split my time evenly between my
divorced parents our baby is five months
old and we don't want to be hauling her
around all day since she naps poorly
anywhere but home we're leaning towards
scheduling different days for different
households but we're dreading the
pushback and anger from whoever gets
told they won't see their grandchild on
Christmas well it's a big thing you know
we went through this for the first
several years of our marriage and our
two families live like an hour apart and
my wife's family you know the parents
are divorced also so same sort of
situation everyone's kind of with one
within a one hour vicinity and that's
precisely the worst situation you could
possibly be in for the holidays because
it's close enough that you're expected
to see everybody but it's far enough
away that that it's a huge hassle to see
everybody so
um not an issue for us now because we
live like 12 hours away from the nearest
set of parents plus we have six kids so
if people want to see us on Christmas
they need to come to us so maybe that's
one of my Solutions is just start start
churning out more babies and then once
you've got a bunch of them then for
every holiday it's like you say you
can't expect me with six kids you got to
come to me okay you want to see us on
the holidays where where are the staging
ground now where we got all the kids you
can come to us
you decide what's best for you what you
what you and your family want to do and
you let the other members of the family
know like this is what you're doing and
that's it
and if they got an issue with they got
an issue with it how does Santa enter
homes without a chimney growing up we
always had a chimney so it wasn't an
issue my husband's family uh didn't but
he never questioned it and his parents
never said anything to him about it I've
heard from other people that Santa gets
a special key that you leave outside for
him on Christmas Eve we just bought a
new house without a chimney and I'm at a
loss he's Magic
once again don't complicate this that's
it if your kid asks how does he get in
the house he's magic we didn't have a
chimney either when I was uh when I was
a kid we'd have the same question how
does it again it's just magic that's it
it's just he just does
next one says I need help with the talk
yeah that's right I need advice on how
to bring up the whole Santa issue my son
is in third grade and still believes in
Santa I'm surprised we've made it this
long I want him to hear it from me not
his friends so I need to do it quick
before the kids start talking about the
holidays
well you sit your kid down
uh and you say listen son
we lied to you your whole life is a lie
nothing is real All Is Lost
have a great Christmas song
no you just just tell him Santa was a
game
that you know that that parents play
with little kids it's just it's a game
it's a fun game it's make believe you
you aren't lying to them any more than
you were
lying uh back when your child believed
in fairies and dragons and and uh
leprechauns and your kid'll be fine okay
people make such a big deal out of this
thing with Santa and telling kids are
they going to be traumatized and
yes if I kill get over it okay
another one says how to keep it going
after they know about Santa is there a
good non-religious way to explain the
Christmas season magic when the kids no
longer believe Santa flies in a sleigh
and comes down the chimney uh no the
answer is no is there a good
non-religious way to explain the magic
of Christmas no there isn't we love
Christmas for non-religious wholesome
reasons so I think we can sort of
explain the magic of Christmas season to
them no you can't I'd like to see you
try
you know what Christmas you know where
that word comes from Christ Mass Christ
Mass it's not a coincidence
uh and it is very specifically to
celebrate the birth of Jesus yeah it's
like imagine saying this about your
neighbor Gary
how can I explain the magic of Gary's
birthday without including anything
about Gary himself
you can't do that with Gary the neighbor
and you can't do that with Jesus sorry
finally kids opening all their gifts at
once versus kids taking turns opening
them so I decided to forego gift
wrapping altogether this year and
decided to only use reusable gift bags
maybe one of the top five greatest
inventions in history mankind think of
all the labor hours that it that it
saves throw it in a bag maybe put a
little bit of decorative tissue paper
you put in there boom you're done anyway
so I usually film my kids opening gifts
and we would all take turns as I'd film
each person opening their gift this year
I'm debating on filming one person at a
time just opening all their gifts at
once kind of like how you watch someone
open gifts on their birthday and
everyone is focused on them just embrace
the chaos man that's it just embrace the
chaos there's no good way to do this
there's no orderly way
every family has spent years and years
trying to solve this problem trying to
figure out the calculus on Christmas
morning what's the best way to open all
the gifts and to avoid the chaos and
kids getting bored or getting antsy or
whatever jealous you know
you can't do it this is this is the same
speech I've tried to give my wife so
many times like it's just it is what it
is and it's going to be chaos just
accept it who are you the one thing I
will say
what Disturbed me the most from this
question
is you saying that you film everyone
open every single gift
stop doing that when are you ever going
to watch this so you you're filming the
whole Christmas morning deal
when are you ever gonna go back are you
gonna go like on some random afternoon
in March and just sit there and watch
57 minutes of people opening Christmas
presents several months ago
just expect just be in the moment rather
than experiencing a moment but in like
in this little box okay
you're in a whole room experience the
entire moment so that's it everyone who
cares about this is in the room
put the camera Down live in the chaos
that is my advice follow all of this
advice and you will Have Yourself A
Merry Christmas
[Music]